You know,
I wanted,
how old's your son now?
He's six now.
And
you hear these,
uh,
stories,
um,
constantly about people remembering the first time they saw Bruce Lee movie.
It's so epic.
I'll never forget my dad took me to the theater,
blew my mind.
Everyone's got a story.
Joe,
he's got his first time he saw Bruce Lee.
So I wanted to make sure I didn't do that too early because then he would
forget,
you know,
cause he forgets special last moments we had together from like three years ago.
I'm like,
I don't remember that,
you know,
cause he's only five,
right,
man,
he's six [inaudible] six.
Imagine how quick your brain is growing and out of money.
You forgot a lot of shit,
you know.
But anyways,
uh,
so I thought maybe I'm going to hit them with the,
I'm going to sit them down and,
and,
and put on,
enter the dragon and blow his fucking mind.
But I don't want to do a tour.
Like,
when do I do it?
I'm thinking maybe I could even wait until these 10 or eight or whatever,
you know?
But he's been doing karate since he was three,
so about three years now he's been doing karate and he took a nun,
chuck workshop class that they had.
So he's got his little,
you know,
those padded nun chucks.
He fucking loves those things,
man.
And I thought,
shit,
he's getting into the nun chucks.
It might be a time to drop Bruce Leon,
his ass.
You know what I mean?
I don't want him to get twisted,
you know what I mean?
Cause he starts,
he starts talking about Jackie Chan and shit like that.
And I'm like,
Oh,
I guess you seen anybody do it on video or only learned it from,
this is what happened.
So He's,
he's all Linden and Chuck's,
he's beaten me up with them all the time.
He loves nunchucks and I,
and I said,
Oh,
then I wore one of those routes of fights shirts and it was Bruce Lee with lunch
looks right.
And he looked at my shirt and he said,
Daddy,
who's the guy with the nun chucks?
And I thought,
okay,
it's time.
It's time,
son.
Sit down.
So,
you know,
kids are so easily brainwashed.
I can get my kid into satanism.
I've seen this little kid.
Yeah.
He's amazing.
He's got the Bruce Lee outfit and everything.
The jumpsuit.
This is amazing.
And he's got,
he's got,
uh,
the game of death sequence down.
It says the video is my son and in parentheses,
a five year old acting Bruce Lee's nunchucks scene.
Yeah.
He ran acts the whole thing.
No for not,
I think he was on like America's got talent or some shit too.
So I sat him down and I,
and I explained to him,
I go the master of the nun chucks the number one guy,
you know,
cause like,
like I was,
like I was saying earlier,
you can get kids to believe in anything.
You get brain.
I could,
I could get my son into Satan easily.
He'd be all in all about Lucifer.
Boom.
I got them under the Brown.
Yeah.
Little kids,
you know.
Yeah,
totally.
He's,
he's so into the Dodgers because his grandpa is under the daughter,
so he's all about the Dodgers and I got them into the browns.
He's all in the Brown's not too,
because then I could get them into,
right.
So I sat him down and I say,
you are about,
I'm going to sit you down and I'm going to show you the master of the nunchucks.
And it's Bruce Lee.
He's number one dude.
He's decry,
right?
He's the greatest martial artist of all time.
I broke them and I sat him down and put them in front of the TV to,
they should have filmed this.
I did you fill the whole thing?
He filmed you saying it to him?
No,
I didn't film that,
but I filmed it.
I filmed him watching Bruce Lee.
Um,
uh,
first I showed him the greatest nunchuck scenes of all time with boost lead that
you can go to youtube and you can get theirs.
There's compilations.
They put together the one from this stuff in enter the dragon and the stuff in a
Chinese connection,
uh,
way of the dragon or return of the Dragon.
And uh,
so I sat him down and go,
I'm going to blitz them with this shit.
I'm going to make sure that whenever he thinks about fucking nunchucks,
he knows that Bruce Lee's the master,
right?
So he's just completely blown away.
Then after I showed him all the nunchucks scenes,
I sat them down and I want him to show him the greatest fight scene of all time.
Bruce Lee versus Chuck fucking Norris.
Come on man.
So I just wanted her to leave that just in his DNA.
And I filmed that.
I filmed him watching a chuck Norris and Bruce Lee.
And he always wants to know he,
he loves,
he loved Bruce Lee instantly and he,
he,
he needs to know who wins the fight.
So it's like daddy does Bruce Lee when I go,
he always,
when sunny always wins and,
but my natural reaction,
cause he,
he's constantly asking questions.
He's constantly,
does he win?
My natural reaction would be just watch,
watch you gotta watch this because it's going to be sweeter.
If you watch it and you go through the ups and downs and it goes,
no,
Daddy,
you need to tell me now.
And I go,
no,
you're going to like it more.
If you just watch it,
you got no daddy does.
Bruce Lee,
when he wants to fucking know,
he don't want to be disappointed.
Yeah.
So he got years old.
He got completely blown away.
So a week later,
a week later,
I got to,
Dang,
you're going to watch the greatest martial arts movie of all time and or the
dragon.
Cause it's Bruce Lee.
Dad,
isn't it?
I go,
yes.
So we sat him down,
we put on and he can't stop asking fucking questions about every God.
Okay Daddy,
who are the good guys and who were the bad guys?
Is he a bad guy or is he a good guy?
So we got it down to three main good guys.
You know,
Bruce Lee is the main good guy.
Uh,
Williams.
I was um,
uh,
his name escapes me.
The black famous martial artists.
Jim Kelly,
Jim Keltner.
Wow.
I forgot about Jim.
Jim Kelly's awesome.
And uh,
he did die in the movie,
which,
I mean,
they were doing that shit back then.
You know what I mean?
A good guy.
And then roper,
John Saxon,
he was the third guy.
It was Roper Williams and Bruce Lee and they were all,
they were the good guys and the bad guys.
Do you remember the bad guys' names?
No.
Han was the,
the,
the dude on the top left.
He's the,
he's the guy with the claws,
former Shaolin monk who win bad and started off selling heroin on this island
and,
and uh,
prostitution rings and all that Shit.
Completely forgot the plot of this movie.
Are you kidding me?
It's the greatest fucking,
I remember watching it,
but it's,
you know,
I didn't take it seriously.
I always thought it was fun.
I was,
I was looked at it and not like,
Holy Shit,
we're going to see this wild action movie.
I always thought of it is because by the time I watched it,
it was Kinda campy and I'm sure watching when I was a little kid had a don't
remember.
Yeah,
you gotta go back and watch a little thing.
Cause every one that's most people's common reactions.
Like you just remember,
you remember the scene with Han with the razor hand.
He had a raise your hand,
he had a claw hand.
You remember Bolo young and they're fighting outside of the tournament.
You know,
you remember all that shit.
You remember,
um,
uh,
Williams,
getting killed.
They hung them.
Uh,
your,
you remember Williams fighting,
Hon?
There's certain scenes everyone will remember and you've just,
you forget about the little scenes and the plot.
So I sit down with my son,
I sit down,
my son and I watching this and my mom or his mom's like,
it's appropriate for,
for a six year old,
right?
It's not gonna get too crazy.
I go,
it's fine.
It's just a bunch of karate.
No,
it's fine.
So she's all like,
Ooh.
So we're sitting there and he can't stop asking God damn questions.
They can't stop asking God to him questions.
The bad guys are Hahn's the main guy,
O'hara Bob Wall,
remember him.
Everybody remembers he had a scar on his face and they,
everyone remembers that.
He,
uh,
was him and his gang were chasing Bruce Lee's sister in the movie and they
cornered her and she had to kill herself.
She just killed herself before they could like rape her or whatever.
People will,
people remember that.
That's a,
another classic scene,
but you don't remember,
you don't think about all the shit in between man,
because the plot,
the plot of the story is Han lives on an island and he has,
he does a lot of illegal shit.
He runs a heroin and prostitution through his island.
Right.
And um,
he has a tournament like once a year and he invites all the greatest martial
artists,
um,
on earth and he tries to recruit them.
He sits them all down and he shows them his,
uh,
like underground operation going on,
you know what I mean?
So he tried to Tom Roper into it.
He tried to talk Williams into an era and a roper almost went for it cause he
was a kind of,
he's a good guy,
but he was like a Gambler,
you know what I mean?
He's kind of shady,
but at the end he's like,
fuck this,
I'm going to do this shit.
So that's what he doesn't,
and he called him Bruce Lee to,
uh,
and he was going to try to recruit Bruce Lee,
but the CIA got ahold of Bruce Lee first.
Yes.
Seriously.
So they get ahold of Bruce Lee and they sit them down in a dark room and playing
a projector and they're showing,
you know,
uh,
they want Bruce Lee to go in there undercover to uncover all the,
um,
uh,
Garanti fits the crime and all this stuff that was going on and doing selling
drugs,
yes.
Drugs and prostitution and um,
and doing mind control on a,
so what,
so I'm sitting there and watching and he wants to know who the bad guys are.
Bolo Bolos a bad guy.
O'Hara who's Bob Wall's a bad guy.
And then Hans,
the main bad guy.
So he's constantly asking questions and then boom,
you forget about the scenes were um,
uh,
Han would,
has like a madam and he's got all these hookers.
There's a hooker seen you forget about the hooker scene.
They send like five girls to Williams.
He was a good guy in roper to try to corrupt them,
you know what I mean?
And Boom,
as soon it,
they're all in their gowns and in robes and Williams is like in a,
in a robe.
And I grabbed the remote and just start hitting fast forward.
And,
uh,
my son's a Lou,
what's going on here?
What's going on here,
dad?
Why are you fast?
Where I'm God,
nothing's going on.
What are they doing?
They're getting ready to go to sleep.
Just forget about that same poom and you forget that there's a,
is this the same?
There it is right there and there's titties and everything,
but um,
yeah,
he got,
he was blown away and a mission accomplished.
He's,
he's Bruce Lee's number one in,
uh,
to him.
And,
but I had made a mistake the next week.
I made them sit down and watch return of the Dragon,
which the end seeing was a great scene with Chuck Norris and the old Rome
Colosseum.
But the whole movie before that is so bad.
It's so bad.
And Bruce Lee directed it and uh,
and wrote it and it was,
uh,
it's atrocious.
It's,
except for the chuck.
So yeah,
except for the egg,
but it's like high school kids put together that terror.
I going to have to go back a while.
You know,
we should do,
we should do a fight companion
and watch enter the dragon.
That would be fucking great dude.
Are you kidding?
Come on man.
Fight companion and watch it.
Look at the scene.
So there it's takes place in Italy.
His uh,
one of his like think his uncle or just or just somebody he knows has a Chinese
restaurant in Italy and the Italian mob.
These guys,
these are the goons.
They're trying to run them out of business and,
and uh,
control their business or Pam off to take the building or something.
And they were,
they are resisting in Italy.
So they send a Bruce Lee from Hong Kong to handle the mob.
It's so corny.
It's fucking bad.
What do you think happened?
I think Bruce,
who's his partying too much,
doing a little blow,
having a good time out on the town,
being a big Hollywood star puts the of this movie and you just got a little
crazy with it.
You know what this before he blew up though,
this is because he did this movie.
He did big boss Chinese connection and this one was his third one.
And then after,
this is when Warner brothers came in and signed him.
That's when they did enter the dragon.
That was his last one.
Enter the dragon was,
uh,
had a,
had a budget.
This is an haven't really any budget.
This is a like just cheap Chinese production.
You know?
It's crazy when you think that there was really no one like him before him.
Like there's Chuck Norris waiting and waiting for,
I'm looking at,
I think it's other thumbs down.
You know,
when you,
when you think about there,
there was no kind of movies like this before this,
this fight scene.
Greatest fights seen worst movie.
How about the grab of the chest hair pulls a chunk of it out.
Oh sure.
I got your chest hair,
bitch.
I mean,
it's funny watching it with no volume two because it's so corny.
It looks so fake and it's all overdubbed and,
and it's,
it's God awful.
But dude,
his martial arts technique,
especially when you think about the fact that this was,
what,
1974 that was like 71 71.
It was finally released in 76,
but he died in [inaudible] 73.
He had incredible technique,
like really good technique.
Like he's kicking technique especially for back then.
You know,
I think because of the Youtube and shit,
there's,
there's so many guys out there that are doing like,
um,
these jumps spinning three 60 wheel kicks.
There was some guy that mill Winkle,
John Jackson had on his uh,
um,
the uh,
Instagram page and it's uh,
a Korean gentlemen doing some fucking ridiculous shit.
Just like jumping 360 degree wheel kicks and like have a series of them
cartwheels flying through the air and doing all these things.
Like none of this was ever in the movies before,
you know,
until like when like maybe jet Li I guess.
No on Bach.
Right.
Cause they're there a next level in terms of like athleticism.
I mean there's that Crouching Tiger Hidden Dragon.
I mean it's all like mystical,
magical show.
This guy is actually doing this.
This is just a video of him.
He starts out normal,
throws like a bunch of front kicks,
throws a bunch of sidekicks,
and then he starts doing jumping wheel kicks,
three 60 wheel kicks,
tornado kicks.
He's just fucking flying through the air and flipping through the air.
Aerial cartwheeled kicks and you're like,
Whoa,
people can do shit now.
And they do stuff in like in martial arts films,
the techniques,
just way better.
They're just way better.
He just got better at it.
Can you put that fight something back up?
But Bruce Lee and Chuck Norris,
see if you could sign that video for while you're looking for,
just while we're talking about the one that's the one thing about Bruce Lee.
All the pads and he flies.
No,
no,
no.
It's just a guy throwing kicks in the air.
He's just throwing kicks in the air.
It's on the Jackson wink.
Yeah,
it's Jackson.
Winkeljohn.
I just looked at Instagram page.
Oh,
this guy's doing it an mmn.
No,
no.
He's doing it in the air.
Just doing it in the air.
Which of their pages should I,
is he planning to use it in m
one Jackson?
Wink MMA.
That one.
Check that one out.
There's a Korean dude.
If you keep going down,
I don't know if he's planning on using in MMA.
My fuck is it?
God Damn it.
I didn't see anything.
Hmm,
okay.
Maybe they were commenting on it.
Fuck somebody had it up.
Sorry.
Anyway,
but with Bruce Lee fight scenes,
what I like about them is you could see him,
although you know him beating up 50 guys at a time,
you know that,
you know how real can that be?
But he does one on one on one fights.
He does a lot of pain team.
He'll do boxing stop,
he'll do wrestling,
he'll do Jujitsu.
You see him mix it up and he's trying to make it,
uh,
a lot more realistic,
like the,
you know,
then you have your classic Kung Fu theater type movies where they're just,
you're
like,
yeah,
that shit is just always a,
so Bruce Lee,
Bruce Lee,
we'll dance around,
he'll throw a jab fade,
kick you in the leg for fake low,
go high and knock you out.
He does that against Chuck Norris in in a way or the dragon.
And if you go back to 1970,
like that kind of martial art technique,
and he was,
he was amazing.
He was also the first guy that figured out how to put a bunch of martial arts
together and just forget about judo,
your karate,
if you had about that,
just,
just use everything that works.
Everything from everywhere.
Yeah.
That was heresy back then.
I mean,
he might've been,
um,
uh,
he may have been the first guy to do that.
Really.
I mean.